let's talk about the nine prescription
medications that have the ability
to
kill you now of course check with your
doctor before taking any of the
recommendations i'm not telling you to
come off these medications i'm just
increasing your awareness on the risks
versus the benefits and the
effectiveness
versus some of these side effects now
the first one on the list
is a very common drug
called cortical steroids so typically
these steroids are the silent
killers
one of the most frequent uses is for
inflammation
allergies autoimmune diseases
asthma
psoriasis etc etc and i've taken
corticosteroids for many many years for
my poison ivy and it definitely had some
serious side effects but i want to
differentiate short-term use versus
long-term chronic use i'm going to be
focusing on more of the chronic
long-term use of these steroids and what
they can do to your body
and i'm not actually talking about the
steroids that you would use
if you're a bodybuilder for example
these are different steroids some of the
side effects includes a loss of appetite
uh moon face like your face becomes
round belly fat
buffalo hump you have this big fat pad
in your upper back
thin skin
increased risk of infection
mood changes osteoporosis
suppression of your adrenal glands and
the worst side effect is the suppression
of bone marrow now you have to realize
that your red blood cells
and your white blood cells and your
platelets
are made
by your bone marrow so when you suppress
the bone marrow
it can lead to some pretty serious
problems because eventually those cells
are going to die and they can't be
replaced so you get a severe loss of
white blood cells and you also get
anemia but you can lose your immune
system so a simple cold or
you get the flu or even a simple sore
throat can end up killing you so people
end up dying from very simple and mild
infections so just make sure if you're
taking
cortical steroids of a chronic nature
that you get with your doctor and really
understand these
serious side effects all right number
two chemotherapy and i'm mainly talking
about a type of chemotherapy
called systemic anti-cancer treatment
where you're taking a certain type of
chemotherapy that affects the whole body
there was a study which i'm going to put
a link down below
that is called the 30-day mortality
after systemic anti-cancer treatment
which showed that this cancer treatment
actually increased the risk of dying
within 30 days now the problem with
chemotherapy is it
kills more than the cancer it kills off
your own immune system it kills healthy
organ tissue it doesn't differentiate
and the other problem is that it doesn't
address the root cause of cancer which
is in the mitochondria instead it
targets the dna of the cell so a lot of
the research right now on the on the
root cause of cancer is actually in the
mitochondria not the dna and ironically
chemotherapy increases your risk of
getting cancer so the side effect of
chemotherapy which is supposed to get
rid of cancer ends up causing cancer
maybe a secondary cancer after you get
rid of your primary cancer maybe a
reactivation of the
original cancer that you had that
initially went in remission because
chemotherapy basically suppresses your
immune system the key system that helps
to fight cancer and keep you alive and
over 200 billion dollars just the united
states is spent on these cancer drugs
and procedures and radiation therapy and
unfortunately 40
of medicare is spent in the last 30 days
of one's life
when they're battling most of the time
cancer all right next one is
antidepressants one in every eight
people is on an antidepressant
antidepressants can increase your risk
of dying prematurely by 33 percent with
ssris there's an increased risk of
suicide there's an increase of risk of
getting a car accident by 40
and if you add alcohol it can increase
up to 70 percent and that is because of
the side effect drowsiness sleepiness
and then you have something called
serotonin syndrome which occurs when you
have too much serotonin you see what
most people don't realize
is serotonin is needed
by many other organs like your heart and
the lungs and the kidneys
and the liver so as you take things to
manipulate serotonin and decrease
serotonin you're affecting all these
other organs as well increasing your
risk of dying from that particular organ
failure so there's a mortality risk of
dying of heart attacks and strokes and
other diseases alright the next one is
the medication called bromocryptin now
that's used to treat uh parkinson's as
well as high prolactin in your blood it
can lead to something called lethal
circulatory collapse
where your blood flow basically stops as
well as something called sudden sleep
and let's just let's say you're driving
for example and then you fall asleep i
mean that's a major
side effect of this medication all right
then we get to clarithromyosin which is
an antibiotic for certain type of
bacterial infections taking this
medication can actually increase your
risk of dying by 27
mainly of a cardiovascular incident and
it can even occur after you stop taking
medication so i don't know about you but
i don't like that risk factor then we
get to another medication called
clozapine and that's for schizophrenia
that has a really high risk of
major side effects
including myocardial death and something
called slow gut which you can get severe
constipation and even die all right
number seven is humero now i've talked
about this in other videos
it's the number one selling medication
for inflammation and everything related
to inflammation and it's a type of
medication called a biologic it actually
suppresses your immune system and
there's a black box warning on the
medication which indicates a more severe
side effect and that side effect is risk
of getting
infections
leading to sepsis which is a systemic
infection and even death and one thing
about this medication is that you don't
want to take it if you
have tb because it can be lethal just
from that all right now we have
colchicine now this medication is used
to treat gout and the fda
put a very high risk on this medication
because it has significant toxicity
which can create death at small doses
like 35 milligrams and lastly we have
digoxin also known as lanoxin and this
medication is usually used for heart
medication for cardiovascular failure
and atrial fibrillation but the problem
with this medication is it can increase
your risk of dying by 20 percent
that's pretty high especially if you're
combining with quite a dime so i just
wanted to bring this video up to
increase your awareness
that if you're on some of these
medications
you might want to get with your doctor
and really review it to see if it's the
best option now if you haven't seen my
video on how to dramatically
take your health to a whole new level
you might want to check that out i put
it up right here